right so
this is your distance because if you've
done a six of Brewery what's about the
only one he can do without with with the
surprising me so six of Bowie no so just
the ski part so the ski part
all right
so I'm safe so so you just need to just
a few times you know with with each and
why I've put you in threes is because
each person attacks different each
person's body weight is different you're
going to have to over the period today
you're gonna have to calculate what
you're dealing with and just being a
robot of doing the same thing every time
I oh I'm okay here look I'm miles away
you know he might extend the next person
might extend more extend more you know
that means that
all right so for the seniors you should
be able to sort of work that out that
you don't need to
do that but I I think for everybody if
you just for now just do that
they cut your hand comes up
in reality your hand wouldn't come up
but what we're doing here is we're
getting our timing
we're getting that we're getting a
timing going
it's as if
his Ken and my finger
has a piece of string to tied to it
okay
it comes from the partner practice
yeah all right just just do that so this
person will cut
reasonably slow at first the higher the
rank faster that you the cut should be
eight
I think
[Music]
hi okay
so the higher the rank the faster you
should be cutting
okay so I just want to show you here
we've got two high level people
they should be really cutting like fast
at their level
but what the problem is and around this
way no that's it cool this way okay what
the problem is
okay so I just want to explain what the
problem is look sensor used when they
are since the how do you teach he said I
just teach
yeah but how do you teach beginners he
said I just teach in other words you
know he didn't make and it's up to you
to grab what you think is important if I
start saying you know you lean this way
for the beginners and more what you know
it's it's we're going to build all day
talking really about things that aren't
important
but this is what the problem is all
right and we all do it I'm in line
I'm in line with my attacker
hey I come here and then what you've
done was this
am I in line with the attacker no now
I've gone smaller and I've actually gone
off the line
without knowing it I've already gone in
self-defense mode but what about the guy
now starts actually cut in where he's
twigged that I've gone
hey that then starts bouncing me out
because I wasn't ready for him to come
over a few centimeters
so the push the one thing about Scentsy
was
he was a stickler for being precise and
if you weren't precise exactly every
time he'd shout and Shout at you so if
you're on the line
hey
a note now
it's no good
so if you star on the line
I am
hey
oh no good sorry that's right my fault
I got your hand and I shouldn't and
um so so be precise know where you are
it's it must are used to say it's not
like one
two it's not like you're not a machine
you know each time
[Applause]
hey
ah
you've got to send to yourself each time
if he starts pumping away and just
attacking
just slow him up a little bit
you know it's your Aikido it's your
advancement that's important
this one tacks the head
this one goes underneath now
underneath
so what I like about this one is
if we're in a car
and I decide to change gears it might be
a different speed than perhaps somebody
else driving the car so I might like to
change gear every 3000 revs
how you might like to change it two and
a half thousand reps so what I have to
do is first I I marry his timing let's
do it real slow at this slow up and down
here I'm up same speed
then I have to quickly accelerate
because I need to be then ahead of him
if I'm here and then
if I can't get there now get in there
by the time he reaches the bottom
so it's no good game
I can't do the technique I want to show
you I can do what I've done and lost the
thing what I can do is a coat of gosh
okay
but the one we're going to do is very
slowly up now I have to accelerate so
I'm there
I'll talk about this more in a minute
at this point in a minute
so I have to accelerate from the top to
the bottom
and you punch from here
okay on a gas mask
the detail we're going to come in closer
with the camera for the detail
what happens is at the bottom of the
strike
your hands in the middle here but what
happens is when you push your hands
sometimes pops through
the hole here
hip hop you go like that and it
so you that's all you get
so I'm going to give you it's nice and
there are secrets in Aikido even if they
pretend there are as I come in as I come
in here as this turns
it allows me to I'm actually going to
now go over to Richard there with my
wrist
so it locks against his wrist
and that's why
he's got a choice whether he just steps
or not
all right so as long as you've locked
him here
everywhere is there the lock
you've locked him
if you don't lock them
you don't lock them
you know you push like that and it can
slip off or
so this is no good
because I've turned I've come around
here
it does that
okay
turn this way
because I've turned here
it's turned him that way
I love it so that's uh that's a little
thing that I hadn't realized you know we
do it sometimes as teachers and we don't
realize we're not actually telling
anybody about what we're doing because
we don't know we're doing it ourselves
but it's all to do with the turn so the
turn is here
here this as long as it's this side
okay as long as it's outside and take a
little
stamp
sorofuni
Tora funi
all right
it's you can't see what's coming out of
a person but we all have to work on the
building of it
and well the problem is it's timing
it's timing
hey right
what's happened is he's he's turned and
he's wasted the last quarter of his body
movement that finger the tips need to go
in earlier before he turns
right there that's yes all right look
attach your Dory I said at the beginning
thank you I said at the beginning it's
it's quite boring because if we don't
know what we're doing
we sort of stand you know all day
thinking why isn't it working let me do
it slowly
I enter I'm with his Ken
as my body turns my arm becomes we'll
say one so when I get to here he's
already there
and then I just step
if you if you get to here at the bottom
you've got nothing to turn any physical
strength now in your hand this is too
late I need to go back here start
putting it on there
right so I put it on earlier but you
can't put it until you're there but it's
the it's the feeding in
of that and then
and then since he you know would punch
like this
to some of you experience ones it'll
make more sense now
ah
Roku
so I'm going to show you broken down
slowly so I come in here I start to turn
I take the Top Hand
and I roll it round and then I go
against his elbow be careful because it
hurts
from what I remember it hurts anyhow
yeah okay nice Camp no more okay this is
Roku now but it's just the star is the
same the Finish is the extra hand on a
gas mask